well good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored the late Queen
kept her cars close to her chest she
understood that the Majesty of monarchy
depends on dignified silence that's how
the royal family holds the country
together even as our politicians rip
each other apart but King Charles and
his laborious apprenticeship as Prince
of Wales we never quite got that silent
Telegram in the 1980s he rejected an
extension to the National Gallery pretty
colorful terms
but what is proposed seems to me like a
monstrous car model on the face of a
much louder and elegant friend
funny enough a monstrous carbuncle on an
elegant friend is how some people view
the Duchess of Sussex well Charles went
on to rankles to John Major in the 90s
with his views on homelessness and
poverty his black spider letters Royal
ministers with barbs about everything
from human rights to the war in Iraq he
branded the plan to send migrants to
Rwanda as appalling it's no secret that
the king is as Prince Philip would have
put it a bunny hugger is a guilt-edged
Eco warrior with an Aston Martin great
car by the way that runs on leftover
English wine and he's been very fond of
talking about it that's why it came as a
great relief when he reassured us that
once King he cubed his opinions firmly
in the Royal vault
and I think it's vital to remember
there's only room for One Sovereign at a
time not two
so you can't be the same as the
Sovereign if you're the Prince of Wales
of the air
but the idea somehow that I'm going to
go on exactly the same way if I have to
succeed
is complete nonsense because the two
the two situations are completely
different
clearly I I won't be able to do the same
things I've done you know as air so of
course you operate within the the
Constitutional parameters
do you your majesty well few issues have
strained our political parameters more
than brexit it's top on governments
ended careers in terms of political
parties inside out the Northern Ireland
problem has been the most vexed of the
lot the whole future of the United
Kingdom could rest on the prime
minister's ability to flock his new deal
to the arch brexiteers and the Irish
unionists so the king's decision to host
EU president Ursula vandelayan at
Windsor Castle yesterday has rattled
cages frankly is smacked of a blatant
attempt to strong-arm unionists and
brexiteers who are also passionate
royalists into backing Sue next deal
it's even called The Windsor framework
and tonight the dup Sammy Wilson
launched an astonishing and predictable
broadside against Charles's involvement
in the deal claiming it puts the future
of the entire monarchy at risk
I don't know whether it was his choice
or whether the government persuade him
to do it but I think it's a very very
dangerous
position for him to have taken it is a
bad decision and if he keeps going down
this route and politicizing the monarchy
then the status that his mother had he
will never acquire and he will put the
monarchy in my view in Jeopardy because
people will simply see it as a partisan
rather than a National Institution
well this debate will only intensify
next month the King's first state
visitors Monarch will be to France and
Germany the great power Brokers of EU
and not a traditional pilgrimage to the
Commonwealth it's a far cry from the
brexit dream of global Britain with
trade deals burnished by Royals voyaging
on a new Royal yacht we don't know
whether Rishi sunak is wielding the king
to get brexit done or if the king
himself was itching to get involved but
this is the future of the Union could
hinge on Northern Ireland the future of
the monarchy actually could hinge on the
king keeping his vow to be silent about
politics and keep his nose out of it
it's in everyone's best interests I
believe if he does that well joining me
now is historian Sir Anthony cell
journalist and friend of the queen
consort peshadow Wyatt and all through
the windows at War Alexander llama
welcome to all of you Alexander to start
with you
it distract me that this is very good
for rishi's sunac if you're trying to
get your deal through positioning the
new monarch of the United Kingdom as
somehow supporting all this is great
politics great Optics in
it'll great though if you're King
Charles in my estimation and you want to
make a statement about impartiality
which is what his mother was of course
renowned for who I think is very
interesting is that the call didn't come
from 10 Darling Street to bring in King
Charles for the meeting with us you know
it was from Buckingham Palace do we know
that we do know that right it said
yesterday that this is from Bucking
Palace not from Downing Street which is
really to me even more problematic to
quote the word of the of the Millennium
I think it's deeply problematic because
I think for what essentially King
Charles is saying is no I'm bored of
being on the sidelines I want to go into
the center I want to have my voice heard
and he listens to man who as you said a
second ago was the black Spider memo man
this is the person who's always always
wanted to have his voice hurt and now we
can see that his sitting down University
for cozy tea together is something that
essentially he's saying I am involved in
this I want to have professionally you
want to get involved in this
first of all I'm interested in what you
say but this is not quite what I've
heard and as we know that the the
Monarch cannot meet a political leader
without the PM's permission I heard that
um
it did come from Danity and he was happy
to do it and he is simply carried I mean
wait a minute can I just finish yeah you
can but I'm just on that one point I
think either way the fact is he did it
so whether it came originally from down
the street Charles has been around a
long time
before you finish my point is it doesn't
really matter actually to the Optics the
Optics are he did the meeting yes and
this in my opinion it flies in the face
of his vowel not to get political no it
hasn't it hasn't because he cannot avoid
meeting political leaders and hosting
them his mother hosted monstrosities he
she hosted Robert McGarvey she hosted
Nikolai church it's not very very
difficult he's not implying that Charles
by hosting uhstia vandalaen is somehow
sanctioning a pro EU if he does it on
the very day that the British prime
minister announces his new proposal he
doesn't have any choice in the matter of
course he did he doesn't have to do it
if he'd refused to do it then there
would have been a constitutional expert
uh yourself now listen you know your
history better than any of us put
together
has this happened before
not like this no uh and therefore it is
uh without precedent the Monarch has
always seemed distasteful people
sometimes uh they became distasteful
after they were seen so it is
um interesting territory and I would
agree with petronella that he would not
have seen it without the prime
minister's endorsement and he is clearly
below the uh the Prime Minister I did
read today may have even been the
spectatorship I did read today that in
1974 Edward Heath persuaded the queen to
go to France to endorse our entry into
the EU so that if that is I I wasn't
aware of that if that is true and that
was what happened in the way that it was
reported that would seem to be not
entirely different to this and doesn't
that therefore appear slightly undermine
your argument that this was without
precedent well it would make me think
that I was surprised the queen did that
and maybe she shouldn't have done
I don't think the monarchs should ever
get involved we probably saw the huge
round when it was reported that the
queen veered towards a view about
Scottish independence
claim at one point that she was probrept
right
they can be very self-serving those
planes but my point is the monarch has
to be impartial because the model
represents everybody in the United
Kingdom not just singular groups of
people he supported but the monarchist
do is that Charles is doing his best in
my view was it was it was it smart
timing is the real question well I look
I think that history will judge this to
have been a wise and a prudent thing
because peers this is where we'll
disagree again because this brexit thing
has gone on and on here is an agreement
this is my view which
um
which brings together most of the nation
Northern Ireland for goodness sake voted
to remain uh we just need to get over
with it I mean we're on board with
brexit but we need to move on the reason
I have a problem with the timing
Alexandria is that this is not a done
deal yet this is a proposal from Rishi
soon now which has the support of the EU
but the real issue will be say the dup
decide you know what we're not having
this deal and they reject it then you
have the king supposedly embracing all
this and then the D you'd be saying
forget it excuse me
ready deal because ultimately Rishi has
raised the game a bit since Boris
Johnson's lamentable effort yeah but the
reality is is for King Charles probably
shouldn't but uh yesterday because the
Optics of it the short-term Advantage is
that the Windsor agreement sanctioned by
the king it looks something which is
given the stamp by The Establishment
before Parliament
and we don't know what the dup are going
to say we don't know what we don't know
what the awkward Squad of conservatives
are going to say I mean I'm sure we're
all waiting with baited breath of Boris
Johnson's view on it I see I I can't
think of anything I'm waiting less
Boris Johnson sticking his big nose into
this once again as you said you just
finished a Tome on Boris Johnson that
shouldn't have I had to put the final
test drugs today today
um which I hope is a is in in some way
reflective of a wider closing of the
chapter on Boris Johnson because I felt
he in his tenure he was actually very
damaging to the office of prime minister
in many ways and I tweeted today not
from a political perspective or partisan
perspective
um because I've actually voted for both
parties over the years but I did tweet
that it's I find it reassuring that in
Richie sunac compared to his two
predecessors at least we at least have
somebody who looks conscientious
eloquent and intelligent and thoughtful
like he's trying to think this thing
through it and also quite Collegiate in
the way he's embraced the EU to try and
get a deal done to get through all this
okay
um I think that's what history will say
and look Boris Johnson had an amazing
opportunity after brexit to um make
Britain's new role in the World remake
to remake the government he blew
everything he didn't even get bricks
so history will say that Boris Johnson
had an opportunity blew it because he
wasn't serious enough didn't know what
he wanted to do didn't know how to take
people with him didn't know how to be
prime minister uh and wasn't serious
enough the only bonus to Boris Johnson
is that it turned out his immediate
successor was even worse
foreign